it is sort of crazy when you're walking
along the streets of New York and people
sort of shout out at you you know said
hey good luck get it up you know that
kind of thing goes like thank you thank
you yeah
nope no problem at home on that but
that's just in the that's in the TV show
Paul Atreides doom start with dune why
not start at the very beginning I got a
message from a casting agent who had
come to Seattle and was auditioning
actors for the role of Paul and of
course I thought it was someone playing
a prank on me turns out it was real and
I did a hotel room audition which
doesn't sound as bad as it I made it
just sound right now it was actually a
camera and we did the scenes in the
hotel room it was a coveted role I guess
in Hollywood at the time they were
looking at a lot of actors so many
different people auditioned for it they
came up with me and how that happened I
have no idea the experience was so
outside the realm of my what I knew to
that point I mean I was 23 just
graduated from acting school no idea
what was happening
honestly but I knew the book really well
and I had played the role of Paul I had
been Paul in my imagination for so many
years and here I was I was able to bring
him to life my screen test the first
screen test I did I'd never seen a film
camera before and I had to do exactly
what I'm doing now I just talked right
down the barrel of a camera for one
speech and I went completely blank and
David came over to me and said I said to
him I said I don't I don't know if I can
do this David and he said to me you're
gonna be great it's gonna be great
you're gonna be fine
I know you can do it that little pep
talk I guess is something that has
continued in our relationship together
David gives me the confidence to do
things that I'm not sure that I can
actually do so that's David Ray Manzarek
the doors
the doors so I taught myself to play all
the music in it cuz I used to play the
piano and I just did it by ear that
Oliver said we were gonna be using in
the movie but of course every couple of
days he would change his mind or they
said no we're gonna change this tune and
we're not gonna do this nor gonna do
this one so I was like ah [ __ ] I just
learned that one we got to filming and
we suffered through these wigs and these
mutton chops that they had to put the
character but before that I remember we
did a lot of rehearsing we were actually
able to play two or three songs for real
and when Val came in and sang hoarse and
it was like kind of like we were this
sort of doors cover band there's
something really magical about putting
together a song and being able to play
it I guess we felt like we were rock
stars for a minute you know every actor
wants to be a rockstar a rockstar wants
to be an actor the film was sort of a
giant machine that just kind of moved
forward and it's kind of consumed
everything in its path that's what it
felt like to me you're working with
Oliver was challenging you know Oliver
gets bored very easily I think you had
your choice you either like could like
do something kind of crazy and get him
sort of interested and excited or you
retreated and you just didn't want him
to even kind of notice that you were
there at all and so I opted for the
disappearing so I sort of just started
to Cape and that keeping the sidelines
you know let him focus on Val and all
that which is really where his focus was
anyway Oliver and I had have an unusual
history he and I met and discussed
platoon way back in the day and we met
and talked and ultimately never it never
came to fruition but it was nice that he
came back around again
and cast me and in the doors as Ray
Manzarek I don't know why he cast me as
Ray Manzarek I'm still trying to figure
that out I wasn't really sure but I'm
glad he did the evil cliff vandercave
Flinstones I was looking for a job you
know and there was this role in the
Flintstones
I grew up watching shows like Beverly
Hillbillies Gilligan's Island
these were my shows you know and so I
just sort of felt a common bond with his
character I also grew up watching a lot
of cartoons and I said well I'm just
gonna sort of channel my inner thirst
and that sort of seemed to work anyway I
got cast and we had so much fun every
day there was a new strange thing that
they'd created for us like we had a Sun
Dial wristwatch and then we had like I
had a newspaper that was made out of
this kind of create crazy resin I still
have the name tag that's on my desk the
evil cliff Vander gave it was brilliant
what they did and I just I had the time
of my life it was so much fun it was
like a thing where I actually got to use
all the hours that I spent sitting on my
couch when I was little growing up
watching TV I was able to channel those
hours into this into this character and
make him come alive
Jeffrey Beaumont blue velvet David Lynch
had given me the script - blue velvet
while we were filming dune I thought it
was really compelling and exciting and
obviously erotic and thrilling you know
and I was very excited you know I wanted
to share this new trajectory with my
family so I showed the script to my dad
and he read it and okay and then I
showed it to my mom and I didn't hear
anything from her and her husband that
my parents had been separated in forest
we married came to me and said you know
she's a little upset about this movie
the script and I was like oh that's not
the kind of thing that you really want
to share with your mom you know
necessarily which I didn't realize at
the time but the girls learned after the
fact we had a fantastic time from the
beginning to end all of us Isabella
Dennis Hopper or Laura Turner myself
that Dean Stockwell we had a great time
filming that a lot of fun there were a
lot of laughs I think that's that
happens in films that are really really
intense like that that you need a lot of
humor to get through all of that as
actors because you go to such dark
places I really just allowed the reality
of the film and the other actors to move
me around in scenes with Dennis Hopper
you know I didn't have to come in
too much of act I just basically reacted
to Dennis it was such a powerful
performance same with Isabella I just I
was in the environment her environment
and followed along and just those
impulses that came out of Jeffery were
coming out of me at the same time and
that's true with laura dern in the same
way i remember in particular there was a
scene where i had to sit on the edge of
my bed after a particularly violent
scene with Isabella and and I break down
of course is a young actor I'm putting a
lot of pressure on myself to sort of
have this emotional release once again
David came in and said he's and he
called me Kayla said Kayla you're gonna
be great I'm gonna do this we're just
gonna take some time here and he relaxed
everybody and he relaxed me and all the
emotions just came bubbling up you know
it was David's guiding hand that helped
get me there Zack Carey Children's
another cartoon show girls another
cartoon film show girls
oh gosh the best intentions that was one
where it was an opportunity for show
girls was an opportunity believe it or
not I thought of it as an opportunity to
like play like a kind of a baddie
you know kind of a villain I was a huge
fan of Vera joven from his early movies
Robocop Basic Instinct so I'm like I'm
excited to work with this guy this is
gonna be amazing this is gonna be a
really intense hard-hitting film I read
the script it was really you know it's
really sexy and edgy and like at a
period in my life when I was trying to
sort of work against sort of maybe the
clean-cut image a little bit I was
trying to do something different this
was my choice anyway we go into the
filming and I have a great time filming
I would sneak away to go skiing when I
wasn't filming which I wasn't supposed
to do but the snow was so good
so I skied that come back and do my
thing I was like oh happy happy happy we
did a scene coming back in Los Angeles
in the pool that whole sequence which
was a long night it was like right near
the end of the filming it's the infamous
pool scene I was exhausted by the end of
it as you can imagine and so cut two
years later or not years later but
months later I would have my first
screening and I watched this movie and
I'm like oh my god this is awful I said
oh my god but you know you have this
this hope like you watched the first
scene and you're like alright that's not
so good but it's gotta get better and I
watch this I was like mmm get any better
okay and I watched the whole thing I
said I
I don't know what to say about this
movie I don't think I can talk about
this movie and so I didn't do any press
which didn't you know make any friends
in the publicity department there at
that time but it was just too difficult
and now of course the movies got this
great life you know lives on and in
infamy I guess and it's sort of a crowd
pleaser but at the time it was it was it
was a pretty big embarrassment you know
it's just like all right you got to go
forward from here but I think my career
definitely took a hit on that one but
you know that's the way it goes
Dale Cooper Twin Peaks so the role of
Dale Cooper in Twin Peaks probably the
most important in my career to date
probably for the entire career it was
one of those things when you start out
to do it and you you're making a pilot
and there were no real expectations that
we would go further it was gonna be a a
two-hour movie of the week if it didn't
get picked up as a pilot ABC decided
that they liked it enough that they were
going to ask us to do seven more so they
all kind of came out at once and
suddenly everything shifted and there
was an explosion and we were like right
at the top of this incredible wave it
was pretty amazing coop is he's like the
old-time lawman I kind of found him as
we as we filmed the pilot because I
wasn't exactly sure who he was he was on
the page you know damn good coffee and
hot that was absolutely written like
that and I and I remember reading damn
good coffee and it was dot dot and hot I
was like and so I just sort of launched
into it and I had this sort of crazy
over-the-top enthusiastic boyish kind of
quality that seemed to work with the
character this is excuse me
a damn fine cup of coffee man damn good
coffee and hot of course because I had
David was a director he was able to help
steer me in certain situations and
moments we were doing a scene where I'm
interrogating Dana Ashe Brookes
character buddy Briggs he gets really
angry no no and I remember one of my
takes I got really angry back at him and
David came over and said knives let's
try something different and I said okay
and so he gets really angry angry and I
sit back and I sort of smile and then I
turned to Michael on Keane and I smile
at Michael and then I turned back to him
and I'm like Bobby it's like this tell
her Bobby here's how this works we ask
the questions and you answer the
questions that we asked it was a choice
that I hadn't really considered but it
was perfect you know David gave me that
gave me that little jewel and I said aha
very good so I was I was learning as I
went along as an actor you know and
David was a master teacher mr. Mayer
Portlandia Portlandia was a was another
crazy thing where I went in to meet
Andrew singer the producer and Fred
Armisen and Carrie Carrie Brownstein and
I I didn't have any idea what they were
doing and they couldn't really tell me
what they were doing I was like okay
well this sounds like it could be fun
and we get to shoot in Portland which is
great and I love everybody you know here
because you're all so talented so okay
I'll just sign on it was just said sure
I'd like to do it not really sure what
I'm doing they would decide well we'll
figure it out and well you know and that
that kind of very loose attitude sort of
kept going through the entire seasons of
it I think we I would show up you know
and we'd have kind of a rough idea about
what we were gonna do we would improv
most everything which was a technique
and a skill that I didn't really have
but I gotten much better at it because
of working with Fred and Carrie this is
the latest one we just got best official
website for cities with populations
under 700,000 in the Pacific Northwest
area
congratulations yeah well I had this one
made and I presented it to myself
Seattle's is the worst oh yeah too many
things everything was just like kind of
like last minute like for instance I was
doing a farmer I don't remember this one
goat farmer and they they found a crazy
straw hat and then they made this kind
of weird beard for me and they said do
you want the must I said no no just the
beard just like this just down here like
this and they made this for me like in a
half hour I mean it was unbelievable we
stuck it on and and there you go and
there's a character that's sort of the
stuff I love and it was so much fun to
work with them that was like a week out
of the summer for me I'd go up and we'd
shoot all my stuff in Portland and hang
out and go to nice dinners and and make
some really fun stuff Riley's dad inside
out how great to do a Pixar movie I mean
it's like an actor's dream right and so
they reached out and they wanted me to
play the dad and I got to be the mom was
Diane Lane someone who I known from the
very beginning when I first came to Los
Angeles we actually had an acting class
together anyway so she plays the mom I
play the dad and you know you work with
no visual they would talk us through
what was happening in the scene that we
were voicing then of course you'd go
back in and you do as they begin to draw
and animate these scenes you would go
back and you would do the lines again
you have to really really use your
imagination and put yourself in that
scene so it's a completely imagining the
process of what these characters do and
looking to the director and a producer
for guidance and also bringing your own
stuff and contributing as much as you
can based upon your my dad nests at that
time so I was a dad at that time so it
was good to be able to you know bring a
little bit of my reality into the
feeding of the broccoli for instance
Trey MacDougal Sex in the City I was
just in in New York I met Desiree who
was later to become my wife and we were
seeing each other and be honest I didn't
really know of Sex in the City before
they reached out I'd heard of it but I
didn't realize it and I remember saying
to Desiree I saying
you know this I'm not worried sure and
she said what is he said sex and said he
said you should meet on that so I met
Michael Patrick King and Jenny Bix we
sat and had a chat and I was really
excited because they sort of had said he
was a heart surgeon he lives on the
Upper East Side be sort of Charlotte's
you know knight in shining armor and I
was like this is actually pretty great
so I was like this is a guy that sort of
he probably hangs out in Central Park he
throws the football with his friends you
know he's like virile and John John
Kennedy you know and then I meet with
them and they say that's that's fine
that's nonsense all those are all true
he also has issues with his mother and
he's not able to get an erection I was
like right okay so anyway that's how we
started the writing was brilliant the
relationship was great
Kristen is fantastic to work with we had
a lot of fun together one of my favorite
scenes just because I thought it was it
was so perfectly strange was when I'm in
the bathtub and I'm so I'm taking a bath
on the toilet is sitting Frances
Sternhagen who plays my mom and she's
smoking which is having a conversation
just a regular conversation and
Charlotte Kristin Davis character
Charlotte walks in and she's like this
is so wrong Charlotte I was just telling
Trey how much you remind me of myself at
your age I often thought we should have
the Train bunny show that that should be
the spin-off Train bunny go off and they
have their own show and you get to see
them and sort of around in New York City
it could be kind of fun they didn't take
me up on the offer though Orson Hodge
desperate husbands I think when I came
in Marc Cherry reached out and I think
he was a fan of Twin Peaks they brought
me in and I was initially working with
teri teri hatcher we had like I remember
they said it was a date they quickly
sort of shifted me over and I started
dating Marcia Marcia Cross Bree and I
remember we really we clicked she's a
Julliard graduate and I'm from the ER in
Washington so we both had training
acting training and I remember joke Joe
Keenan would write these fast-paced
dialogue scenes for the two of us this
conversation is over the door stays open
I want it closed no you stink and you're
a [ __ ] here's the difference I can get
clean
it was really fun working with Marsha
she's extraordinary actress and we had
really good chemistry I think it was
everything was like really good because
we come I was coming to work and it was
literally ten minutes from my house one
big happy family working outside for the
most part I loved the cast and crew
again and one of those were I think I
was probably supposed to be on for a
year or two I lasted for I think I was
on the show for six years oh my god
see what happens time goes when you're
having fun khau Szabo agents of shield
agents of shield sort of came there was
this role and they reached out again
kind of funny these things come she had
this sort of secret and he was tortured
I loved it as an actor I loved that
challenge and I was able to sort of let
a lot of things just kind of go as an
actor it was it really there's not a
pivotal moment but it was something that
I felt very I was ready for all those
emotions that I had had a difficult time
dealing with when I was maybe younger
and blue velvet suddenly everything was
available to me so I was able to bring
this guy who was alternating between you
know anger and and crying and laughing
and kind of manic it all was all sort of
the gel for me Dale Cooper dougie Jones
mr. C and Twin Peaks there was a long
lead-up to finally beginning filming on
that David Lynch
called me on the phone and said he
needed to talk to me about something
very important and he came to New York
and we sat in his hotel he told me they
found a way back to Twin Peaks and he
said would you like to be involved and I
said David I never left when Peaks do
you know that so that's how we sort of
sealed the agreement over a cup of
coffee of course David have has me over
to his house in Los Angeles because he's
said you're gonna have to do you know
there's some pretty good intense stuff
here and which it gets me very excited
but the same time was a little nervous
too so I started reading these pages and
I realized that there were three
characters he was asking me to do Cooper
must remember him this character of
Dougie which is a little confusing to me
at the time and then this badass named
mr. C and that was the one that made me
pause and go okay I've never done this
before I don't know if I can do it I I
think I can do it but I'm not sure
and he has to be the most dangerous
person you've ever met and I'm like okay
well it's why I'm gonna have to do it I
found my way into this character and I
begin to take on this persona I remember
the first day with this guy and walking
out and and creating his character I was
kind of stunned inside and David was
stunned and we said we got him we got
this guy
[Music]
you
[Applause]
doesn't that hurt your arm when I go
like that as an actor there are a few
moments when you really at least for me
when you really feel like wow okay I'm
in uncharted territory and that's where
I felt I was and it was thrilling
Isaac is heard the house with a clock in
his mouth Eli Roth
our director reached out to me for this
character and I was immediately charmed
by this character he's a baddie he's
bent on world destruction blah blah blah
but he has at least as I read it he had
a charm and a panache and a charisma
that was undeniable and I said that's
what I want to do I was surprised
pleasantly surprised that they put on
these this prosthetic which was quite
extreme more and more extreme that I
thought I was going to be when I first
started I was gonna be just a few little
dabs here and there
but they put on these prosthetics which
completely changed my whole appearance I
would actually really really liked it I
like disappearing behind this mask even
more so I love the idea that this guy
looks a certain way which is not very
pleasant but maintains this you know
bravura you know and belief in himself
he believes he's the sexiest man in the
room and to be able to play that looking
the way I looked with the actors that
were with me that was a fun experience
and that's where I think the prosthetics
really aided in the creation of the
character